welcome back everyone today we're going
to be designing an ad click aggregator
so just as a reminder I'm Evan I'm a
former meta staff engineer and
interviewer uh and I'm currently
actually the co-founder of hello
interview.com and so hello interview is
a site where we help software
engineering candidates prepare for their
upcoming interviews and we do a lot of
things to do this but one way is via
mock interviews with current and former
Fang Engineers just like me uh we also
have a lot of free written resources AI
Tools in any case I highly recommend you
all check it out but I won't blab on too
much about that um ad click aggregator
is a super common question it's one
that's asked a lot at many of the top
companies I'm sure you guys have heard
this or seen it come up uh as you're
searching for common questions it's one
that I've asked myself plenty of times
so we're going to go through it exactly
as if this was a real interview I'll
interject with tips from an
interviewer's perspective talk about
what I'm looking for at each level
respectively uh as well as kind of the
common Frameworks and and general
strategies for approaching a problem
like this now of course as always if
videos aren't your thing and you would
prefer I've also written up a detailed
answer key to this question over here at
hello interview.com so you can scan
through this uh you'll be able to see
breakdowns of what are bad good great
answers
Etc if you also want to have a say in
which questions we break down next you
can see this list is growing I think up
to 10 then you can click on that suggest
a question and vote for the question
question you want to see next I'm
working on design a distribut a
WebCrawler right now since that's the
the one that's voted most highly last
bit of housekeeping you'll get this
whiteboard in the description below
there's also links to the previous
questions or the previous videos as well
as my LinkedIn if you want to connect
and chat feel free to do so but without
further Ado let's jump into
it all right before we dive into solving
the problem let's take a moment to just
talk about what our general approach is
going to be what's the road map that
we're going to follow to try to answer
this problem so up here I have the road
map that we followed for the previous
three videos If folks have watched those
was were Ticket Master Uber and Dropbox
and this is the road map that I suggest
candidates follow for product design
questions these are the questions where
you're designing a user facing
application like Ticket Master or Uber
so we go over those the API uh and the
core entities before getting into the
highle design now ad click aggregator is
a little different this is what we at
hello interview refer to as an
infrastructure design question as
opposed to a product design question and
so with these questions you take a
slightly different flow through the
interview you'll still Define your
requirements these are the functional
and non-functional requirements of the
system uh you'll still do a high level
design and we'll still go into deep
Dives that satisfy uh those
non-functional requirements but instead
of core entities and API which make less
sense in the context of a system that is
not as user facing we instead do system
interface and data flow so you'll see
this later on we'll do it together but
we're going to clearly outline what data
the system receives and what it outputs
this is going to establish a clear
boundary of the system's functionality
and then we're also going to just
describe we list out at a high level the
sequence of actions or processes that
the systems going to need to perform uh
on that input in order to produce the
desired outputs so so a slight
modification here um but only slight so
just to recap that we're going to start
with requirements both functional and
non-functional requirements
non-functional being really critical
these are the qualities of the system
and then we'll do that system interface
and data flow I just described we'll
sketch out a highle design this will be
us going over to the Whiteboard and
drawing the components with arrows for
the main goal of the highle design is to
satisfy our functional requirements of
our system so it'll be relatively simple
at this point and then we're going to
end with our deep Dives and our deep
Dives are going to be where we go deep
to satisfy the nonfunctional
requirements of the system so all of the
qualities of the system that we end up
defining so let's get started and and
walk through this flow
together all right before we even jump
into the requirements let's just take a
moment to discuss what the heck is an ad
click aggregator this isn't as straight
forward as being told design Yelp or
design Ticket Master which are systems
that that you've probably used directly
you may may not know what an ad click
aggregator is so as a brief overview an
ad click aggregator is a system that
collects and Aggregates data on ad
clicks so when ads show up on websites
users click them those users get
redirected to the ad and we log that
click and then we're able to show
advertisers metrics how effective is
their ad how many users are clicking on
it over what time periods Etc um so
that's kind of a high level what a n
click aggregator does it actually leads
us really nicely into our functional
requirements where we're going to go
next
so when you start any interview you're
going to outline the functional and the
non-functional requirements the
functional requirements are like the
features of the system uh this is the
highlevel you know users what do users
expect from this system and users might
be external users internal users they
may even be machines or apis but what's
the expectation for this system uh I'm
actually going to paste in the
requirements so you all don't have to
watch me type like in some of the
previous videos and we'll go over them
together so the first one is that users
click on an ad and the expectation is
that they get directed to that
advertiser's website you click on a Nike
ad you go to nike.com pretty easy we'll
talk about how to accomplish that and
there's a little bit of nuance there the
second functional requirement maybe the
more interesting one is that advertisers
expect to be able to query for click
metrics over time so they might have a
query to say for my Nike campaign I want
to see how many clicks we've had over
the last week maybe with a granularity
of an hour and then they zoom in to the
last day and they want to see with a
granularity of 1 minute and so that 1
minute is the minimum granularity that
we're going to
support now in an interview it's often
times useful to be on the same page with
your interviewer about what's out of
scope so it's not necessarily a
requirement that you write this don't
feel like you have to some candidates
kind of really pressed to try to get
something here it's only if it comes
naturally that you have some questions
for your interviewer that are clearly or
that you want to get kind of agreement
that they're out of scope then you could
do this some things that I might want to
clarify out of scope is AD targeting and
serving basically that decision of which
ad shows up on the page for me we'll
call that out of scope we'll abstract
that away we're not going to worry about
cross device tracking we're not going to
worry about integration with offline
channels so we're worried about just on
our website like you could imagine we
run Facebook or some other site just the
ads that show up on our site not us
having some ad platform that allows you
to show our ads on other
sites great so those are our functional
requirements of the system next up is we
do the nonfunctional requirements and so
the non-functional requirements are the
qualities of the system what qualities
does this system need to have in order
to provide a good user experience and
that user experience again might be an
external user an internal user whatever
it may be in our case it's our users and
our
advertisers and so before we get into
the non-functional requirements
particularly for these like
infrastructure design questions it'd be
good for us to get a sense of scale
first so I might ask my interviewer uh
what's the scale of the system
specifically how many ads are we going
to support at any given time and they
might tell me in our case we're going to
go with 10 million ads at any given time
on the platform and then we'll do 10,000
ad clicks per second at Peak so at our
Peak we'll have 10K ad clicks per second
that's important we want to know that
because that's going to have some
influence on our design particularly
around scalability
so now as we go into those
non-functional requirements this is
where you think through those ility
statements I just mentioned one
scalability there's also low latency
there's the Integrity security item
potency like these are some of the terms
that you start thinking about with
non-functional requirements but instead
of just writing those down plainly and
many candidates do this for what it's
worth they just write down those words
and it's it's wholly
uninteresting instead identify which of
those are uniquely relevant to this
system and then do two things
put them in the context of this system
and then quantify them where appropriate
so again let me let me paste in the
non-functional requirements that I
sketched out here and we can talk
through them so here we are so some
non-functional requirements we just
talked about the scale of the system
it's a lot 10 million ads and 10,000 ad
CPS per second is is pretty decent scale
so we're going to need scalability but
not just scalability scalability to
support a peak of 10,000 clicks per
second we also want low latency but but
again not just low latency we want low
latency analytics queries and we want to
bound that to be less than 1 seconds so
we put it in the context of the system
what needs to be low latency the queries
from advertisers and then what's the
quantification less than one second uh
we want the system to be fault tolerant
and have high data Integrity frankly I
actually could have put these in the
context of the system a little bit
better but this basically means that we
don't want to lose clicks um this often
times influen is even how much we pay
out advertisers or how much they need to
pay excuse me um so we want to make sure
that these click data is accurate and
then we want to make things as real time
as possible so on the analytics queries
that data should be as up toate as
quickly as we possibly can at least
within that one minute gr
granularity and then lastly something
that'll be important is this item
potency of add clicks so this goes
towards the security of the system
people often times want to spam uh
systems like this in order to make it
look like an ad is getting clicked on
maybe more than it is and so if a user
goes to an advertisement and click click
click click click click click click
click click click or they have some bot
do that we should only count that as one
click so any given user should only be
able to click on one particular instance
of an ad or ad placement uh once some
things out of scope I'll just mention
we're not going to worry about spam
detection beyond the item potency
concern you know real systems have
complex machine learning models that
handle that we're not going to be able
to filter by additional things in our
analytics like demographic profiling or
or setup conversion tracking or anything
like that we're going to keep it
relatively simple so at this point we
have a pretty good understanding of the
requirements of our system and what we
need to build um we're going to take
this and move on to the next
section now that we have the functional
and the non-functional requirements down
the next step for us is to do that
system interface and data flow and so
what does this mean again this means
clearly outlining what data the system
receives and what it outputs so we're
establishing that clear boundary of the
systems functionality we can start by
doing that so for example the input to
our system is going to be click data
that's coming in from our users and then
also you know uh Advertiser queries so
Advertiser queries those are coming in
on the other side from the advertisers
those are the two inputs the outputs
respectively then are from the users the
output's like a
redirection and then from the
advertisers the output is the aggregated
click metrics right so those are the
inputs and the outputs of our system now
in the actual interview if this is
useful to you do it if it's not don't
for this question it was pretty
straightforward so maybe we could have
skipped it um but I think it's still a
good step to follow it really kind of
helps build things linearly in your mind
and makes it a lot easier for when we
now go into data flow and in this data
flow section we're just going to jot out
a simple linear list of the steps that
are necessary to transform our input to
our output so this could be as simple as
something like this first is that we
have click data comes into the
system cool that part is pretty
straightforward next we know that user
is
redirected Okay the third thing is that
we probably want to validate uh that
click data make sure that we hand that
item potency concern that we talked
about in our non-functional
requirement and then the next thing that
we would do is we would log that click
log that raw click data so click data
logged the next thing is that we need to
aggregate it click data aggregated so
data comes in we validate it we log it
and now we run some aggregation process
over it in order to make sure that we
can put it in a format that's eventually
read optimized and so that we can have
the aggregated data queried by
advertisers all right this is kind of
the highle flow of how our systems going
to work and importantly this highle flow
should meet all of your functional
requirements that you outlined earlier
as it does here users click and get
redirected advertisers can query those
steps are one two and six
respectively um and then you know it
should take advantage or take note of
your inputs and outputs that you define
so the goal here is that you have a
really clear understanding albeit
incredibly high level of the steps that
are necessary and you're going to use
these steps to inform Your highlevel
Design which is where we end up going
next so the key with these interviews is
that each of the sections before in this
road map fuel or inform the subsequent
sections so the functional requirements
and in part the non-functional
requirements but largely the functional
requirements informed our inputs and
outputs in data flow here and our data
flow is going to inform our high level
design and then we're going to go from
there so here's our high level data flow
now let's get into that high level
design all right here's where the
interview starts to get a little bit
more fun we've set the foundation we've
laid the landscape we know what it is we
need to build but now it's time to
actually build it so we have the
Whiteboard we use our squares circles
Etc arrows and we start to sketch out a
high Lev design of the system and as a
reminder the goal of this highle design
is to satisfy our two core functional
requirements that's the main goal here
and the way that we're going to do that
is by ensuring that we have a high level
design that kind of follows and supports
this clear data flow that we outlined
which itself was derived from those
functional requirements right so again
everything's building on one another so
just a note to say that if you are a
midlevel candidate this is like E4 L4
Etc um then you probably getting to this
highle design within 15 minutes that
should be what you shoot for if you're a
senior or staff candidate ideally you
moved a little bit quicker you got about
10 minutes until you got here so there's
plenty of time for you to do the highle
design and deep Dives so as we get
started let's first just focus on this
kind of a user clicks on an ad and
they're redirected to the advertiser's
website it's the very first thing that
we're going to be focused on here so we
can have our browser don't know why it's
audit there we go we can have our
browser and what our browser is going to
do is our browser is going to click on
an ad and when we click on an ad we'll
hit our service which is going to
be some click processor service we'll
call it so click processor service and
then just to kind of round things out
for clarity we mentioned this was out of
scope and I'm going to keep it
abstracted but it's going to be
necessary because there's some data that
we might talk about here that's going to
be relevant you'll see this here in a
second I have some ad placement service
first so the browser reaches out to the
ad placement service says give me some
ads we send it over some ads it gets the
ads from some ads DB which again it's
not the focus of this interview but it's
necessary for us to know what data is
going to be entering our system so this
is going to have the data of advertise I
spelled that wrong didn't I I'm just
going to say ads save myself the trouble
this is is going to have some ad ID it's
going to have the redirect URL and then
it's going to have some additional
metadata that you know we don't care
about this will be the actual ad the
image the text all that stuff right not
that important for our purposes so the
browser is going to get some ads they're
going to get rendered here a user is
going to click on the ad and then that
click is going to go to our click
processor at which point of course
according to our functional requirements
that user is expecting to go off over
here to the ads website ne.com was the
example that we used earlier so there's
two ways that we could do this the first
way is that we send the redirect URL
here and when the user clicks on this
they have the uh the redirect URL and
they just navigate to the redirect URL
and then immediately after or in
parallel we send the click event so
that's the first way super simple super
straightforward now the downside with
that approach is that whether they're
sophisticated users who hate advertisers
or more likely somebody uh who who has
an ad blocker what they would end up
doing is that they would just extract
that redirect URL U from the Dom here
and they would just redirect to it kind
of directly without ever sending this
post request to our click processor so
they would get what they want what they
want is to be able to go to the ad and
then you know not care about the big bad
advertisers getting their metrics and
being able to to to click on it and
count it so they can just take that
redirect URL which would be in the Dom
here and navigate directly to it while
kind of subverting the process of
actually loog bling that click so that's
what what what could happen there um and
obviously that wouldn't be ideal another
thing that we could do is that the ad
placement service could only send over
the ad ID and this is actually what
we'll choose to do in this case so then
when we click on it we send a click
event with that ad ID and then this guy
is going to have to ask the ad
DB ask the ad DB you know what is the
redirect URL maybe I'll make this clear
and just say get redirect URL
given the ad
ID and then we'll return uh we'll log or
click we'll talk about that in a second
and then we'll return a 302 to redirect
302 redirect response with the redirect
to that URL so this way they can't
subvert us they have to come through us
they have to get their click logged and
it's only once their click is logged by
The Click processor that we can return
with our 302 using the redirect URL so
they end up going where they need to go
this is also nice for what it's worth
because we to pend additional things to
the query parameter some additional
metad data to talk about where the click
happened Etc that's out of scope for our
design um but gives us more control by
making them first have to come to our
server and then we'll respond with that
redirect HTTP response so this is the
way to kind of easily satisfy that first
functional
requirement now for the second
functional requirement we want to make
sure that advertisers can query click
metrics over time so that's where we
would go next let me take a step back
quickly to just say that maybe in a real
interview what you would do is you would
work through your data flow here
sequentially noting that we've done one
and two you'd satisfy three through six
um but I'm going to kind of detour just
a bit if you all will let me because I
try to make these videos show you uh
kind of what would be required or what
are the expectations of a range of
levels from mid-level all the way up to
staff so I'm going to start with
something kind of crappy here that a lot
of mid-level candidates reasonably kind
of do and then we'll talk about why it's
crappy and we'll build up to something
better note though if you're a senior or
a staff candidate you know you won't
start with the crappy solution you'll
you'll start a little bit further on um
towards the better solution but I'll
call each of those out as I go bear with
me so again we want advertisers to be
able to query click metrics so the first
thing that we need to do is we need to
make sure that we store click metrics so
to orient oursel again the browser has
just clicked on something there was a
post request to our click processor
service and now we need to persist that
click dat data so what I'm going to do
is I am going to add an arrow here and
I'm going to add a new database this is
going to be our click DB and our click
DB is going to store that click data and
so these are going to be click events
those click events are going to be
things like they'll have an event ID
they'll have the the ID of the ad that
was clicked they'll have the user ID if
they're logged in we'll talk more about
that later and then they'll also have
the Tim stamp so this is a simple click
event again in reality at Google Etc ET
there's actually a lot more information
that's stored with the click there's
information about the user's browser
demographics you know kind of this large
blob of additional metadata but as this
is usually asked in an interview as I
typically ask it in an interview that's
not required we keep it pretty simple so
it's it's just this data so we stored
The Click data in our click DB and then
the simplest thing that you could
possibly do is you could have up here
some query service so I'm going to call
this the query service SVC for short and
then I'm going to have my advertisers
browser so
Advertiser browser so my Advertiser
decides that they want to see all of the
clicks from the last week or so the
query service then constructs a query to
query our click DB to get them that data
this is the simplest thing that you
could possibly do and especially for
mid-level candidates like this is this
is a great start it's not going to be
passing in an interview but it's a great
start a couple things that we'll know is
that this event database has to be
optimized for a lot of Rights so for
whatever reason in in most of like the
system design especially interview
Literature Like Cassandra is the main
choice here um frankly there there are
plenty of databases that work well here
um but let's let's go with Cassandra for
now Cassandra is a fine choice and
Cassandra uses a sword structure that
resembles lsms so what it does is it it
inserts and updates into a log like
structure which is known as a mem table
and importantly this mem table is in
memory which allows these rights to be
so fast and then periodically we'll
flush those mem tables to disk into a
file that's called an SS table I won't
go into too much detail there feel free
to look that up on your own if you're
interested it's not strictly necessary
to know these sorts of things in an
interview the extent would be that you
know Cassandra is optimized for rights
ideally if the interviewer were asked
you why is it optimizes for right you
could say a little bit more um but
frankly that's not a question that's
asked all that often um but importantly
while these SS tables are optimized for
reading a specific r
so for example if I want a specific row
based on an event ID that's that's easy
and fast in Cassandra they're not
optimized for range queries or
aggregations which is exactly what we
need here right so we're going to end up
having some query and actually let me
maybe come up here and copy and paste
what one of those queries would look
like so that you guys can see it I'm
going to pull this right off of the
document from our written resources that
we have um so the query might look
something like that right I want to get
all of the the total clicks um or I want
to count the number of total clicks and
from event unique users Group by a given
ad ID over some period of time and so
this aggregation query is going to be
super super super slow it's going to be
super slow on Cassandra in particular
but the reality is it would actually
still be really slow on post grass
Dynamo DB Etc especially as you open up
these time Windows realizing that
there's 10,000 of these clicks per
second that's a lot of rows to munge
Aggregate and count so for that reason
when when an Advertiser goes to hit the
query service this isn't going to
satisfy those non-functional
requirements which require that this be
pretty fast right less than one second
this will be certainly longer than one
second so it's bad um now often times I
say get down something simple that works
for the functional requirements and then
move on to the Deep Dives and satisfy
the non-functional requirements and the
Deep Dives and that's true I stand by
that but for some things it's like you
can't have something that is so bad in
your eye Lev design you should have it
be a little bit better than this right
so I'm going to say this would not this
would not pass as a high level design at
any level of interview including
mid-level um so let's do something
better right the key here is that this
query is slow so instead we're going to
need to aggregate the data and then put
it into some database in a way that it's
read optimized so this database is write
optimized it can handle lots of wrs
coming in quick great but it's not read
optimized the read is super slow so we
can handle that by pre- aggregating and
then putting it in some read optimized
database in a format that's read
optimized hopefully that makes sense and
it's pretty straightforward so let's
talk about the the ways that we would do
that now what we can do is we can use
spark so we can put a spark layer here
spark and what spark is going to be is
it's going to be a map ruce job so it's
essentially going to go over Cassandra
it's going to go across all of the
shards from Cassandra get all of the
data and then aggregate them so run some
map reduce job to aggregate them at
these minute intervals and so it's going
to write them at a minute interval let
me move this up it's going to write
these at a minute
interval to some read optimized
database and so we can call this Su olap
database olap stands for online
analytical processing um they're kind of
the common database of choice when
you're doing query aggregations now
given how simple actually our functional
requirements are of just looking at ad
click data over time Windows ol op's
probably not necessary like you could
use anything here you could use a Dynamo
DB you could use post graphs whatever um
but in a real system you would have a
lot more Dimensions that you could query
by which case olap becomes more more
interesting more necessary um let me
make this Arrow be the other
direction okay and then spark needs some
way to start so let me just just kind of
throw that here so KRON scheduler
boom so what's going to happen here is
we're going to have this Chron job and
this Cron job is going to kick off spark
every say five minutes or so and so
every five minutes Spark's going to run
it's going to grab all of the data that
is coming from in the click DB and it's
going to aggregate them using map ruce
and then it's going to write those
aggregations to our read optimize
database here and those optimizations
might be at ID minute so this is like
the modulo minute right not second are
not events anymore and then total clicks
right so that's kind of the main data
that's going to be stored there let me
write that in the same format with our
dashes and now when the advertiser goes
to query this is going to be so much
easier they're going to give us the ad
ID that's already been aggregated um and
it's going to be significantly quicker
right hopefully that makes a lot of
sense um now one thing you might be
noting is like why two databases here
why not run spark do some aggregation
and then write it back to the same
database and so the first argument is as
I mentioned this is going to be
optimized for wrs and not optimize for
reads even after being aggregated
because of the way that we use SS tables
here now you could say okay cool that's
fine don't don't use Cassandra and you'd
actually be smart to say that like the
reality is
10,000 uh clicks per second thus 10,000
transactions per second that's not that
much like we can handle that on a well
optimized
postgress instance on good Hardware we
can handle that with Dynamo DB we can
handle that with most modern databases
and if you have postgress then you know
we've got some indexes built and it's
much easier to do range queries so
that's totally possible but even with
that being said there's two main reasons
why you'd want to separate out these
databases so the first is that it
reduces contention so separating the
right heavy and the read heavy workloads
reduces contention and resource
competition which is going to you know
improve the overall performance so if
you have a ton of Rights uh reads coming
in or excuse me a ton of Rights coming
in then your reads might be slower
because they're waiting to get a
thread and then the second thing is
Fault isolation so issues in the right
path don't necessarily impact issues in
the read path and vice versa so if this
goes down or we have some problems and
we'll talk about fault tolerance later
but our analysts can still read and if
this goes down and our analysts can't
read anymore well we're still logging
cck and we'll be able to back fill so
that's going to be that's going to be
really
important um so this now is passing for
a mid-level candidate um this is
actually getting pretty close to overall
passing for a mid-level candidate for
what it's worth but we'll still going to
get one of those non-functional
requirements this is a great starting
point for senior and staff candidates
but we're going to expect a bit more
specifically because you'll know some of
our real-time uh non-functional
requirements aren't met we haven't
talked about item potency fault
tolerance
um we did kind of do okay to handle
these two um of the nonfunctional but
that's where we we ultimately end up
going next so let me stop here and then
we'll we'll take it to deep
Dives all right now it's time for us to
move on to the Deep Dives so we should
have satisfied our functional
requirements and now we're going to move
on to our deep Dives with the goal of
satisfying all of these nonfunctional
requirements so let's do exactly that
the first one that I want want to kind
of pay attention to is the latency
issues so we want to be able to get data
into our system as real time as possible
and especially this minute granularity
what would happen with our system now is
if we run our spark job every 5 minutes
or so then it's going to take you five
minutes until you can see how your ad is
doing and as an Advertiser maybe you
just launched an ad and you want to see
right away or maybe you just really want
to see what happened in that last five
minutes and right now we don't show you
any of that so that's not great so we
could obviously run spark more
frequently we could take that down to
two and a half minutes to one minute
maybe 30 seconds but eventually you
reach a point where you run the spark
job so frequently there's a lot of
overhead to start a spark job to run the
map produced to get the rights and it's
decently computationally expensive so
you you hit a limit of how frequently
you can run this thing so let's talk
about what some of our other options are
instead now in a real interview I would
probably just you know delete components
here and build upon this but because I
link these whiteboards in the in the
comments or in the description of the
YouTube video I'm going to leave this
here and I'm going to come down and
actually just paste a new version and
this is what we're going to work off of
now so this is kind of the spark
solution it's okay potentially passing
even for a mid-level candidate if we
could talk about some more things in
depth um but now is where we're going to
go a bit deeper particularly for those
senior and staff candidates so Spark's
not going to cut it anymore I'm actually
going to go ahead and get rid of spark
we just talked about the reasons why
it's not great instead what I'm going to
do is I'm going to introduce a stream
and so I'm going to introduce a stream
like CFA or Kinesis I'm going to do
Kinesis uh either one would work this is
going to be a click event stream and so
when clicks come in our click processor
is going to put those clicks on the
stream and from there instead of having
our our click DB we might actually come
back to that just a quick note but I'm
going to remove it for now
uh we're going to need a stream
aggregator and so I'm going to put in
something like
flank so I'm going to have Flink here uh
spark also actually supports stream
aggregators uh kind of a different
implementation of spark than the one
that we had previously um but I'm going
to have Flink here and so what Flink
does is it takes click Events off of the
stream in real time and it Aggregates
them so in memory it keeps some inmemory
data structure
that's well I'm going to get rid of
those cuz that seemed too hard to write
but you know is the minute maybe this is
maybe this is minute
45 um and count and the counts at 12 and
it keeps this in memory and keeps
updating them and what you can do in
Flink is that you specify an aggregation
window and so in our case our
aggregation window would be 1 minute and
so for 60 seconds it's going to say this
is minute 45 and it's going to continue
to increment this as it's reading off of
this stream D ding ding ding ding ding
ding and it can do this for each of the
ad IDs so for add so for ad ID number
one this is minute 45 and we're going to
count 12 more come in this goes to 13 14
15 16 17 whatever as the minute ticks
and it becomes minute 46 then we write
this aggregated data off to our database
so at this point bang we can write that
data directly
here and so this guarantees that we're
at least much more real time now at this
point you can read data at the minute
marks exactly after a minute finishes
maybe not exactly but nearly exactly
after a minute finishes you can read
that minutes data because it was written
directly from Flink uh which was our
stream aggregator now the aggregation
window let me write that down because
that's useful so the aggregation window
this is the terminology that describes
the period in which data is grouped or
aggregated so that was one minute for us
and then Flink actually supports
something called flush intervals too and
flush intervals are super crucial for
latency sensitive applications like what
we have here so we could Define maybe a
10-second flush interval what flush
intervals are is they're the interval at
which intermediary results are flushed
from the system so we can be counting in
the minute right and keep aggregating
over a minute window but once we hit
second 10 we'll write whatever we have
and when we hit second 20 we'll write
whatever we have and we write hit second
30 we write whatever we have until we
get to the minute and then the data is
complete and what this means is that in
an ad as an Advertiser if it's 427 as it
is for me right now and it just started
at 427 then after 10 seconds I can read
the partial data so nearly in real time
I can know how many clicks have come in
in the first 10 seconds of this minute
at least right so you end up kind of
seeing a graph probably seeing these
right like if you have a graph and maybe
this is our data this is time at minutes
this is the number of clicks and then
here's our kind of partial data and it
would be dotted is the way that this
usually happens over ux right showing
that it's partial it's not complete data
this is where it is up until this point
so we'd be able to do that with these
flush intervals in Flink which is super
nice so ultimately this system is much
better because it satisfies that real
time or new realtime component now our
advertisers can get the data almost
immediately so this for senior and staff
candidates could be where you started
many candidates that I interview for
this question already know that this is
going to be a stream processing question
they start with this as their high level
design and that's great fantastic we'll
build on it from here some candidates
don't they start with that uh kind of
more simple bash processing
implementation with spark above that's
okay I usually then point out to them I
don't like that 5 minute um kind of
interval how can you do better and then
they arrive at something like this from
this we build on the the further the
further deep Dives excuse me as we'll do
now the next Deep dive I want to tackle
is maybe the scaleability to support a
peak of 10,000 clicks per second so
let's talk about that for a bit what can
we do to make sure that we can scale
well it should be relatively
straightforward so first off we can
scale our click processor or AB
placement Services horizontally so we're
going to have more instances of these we
can do that dynamically most modern
systems allow you to scale Services
dynamically based on CPU or memory
thresholds that are reached so if we you
know occupy 80% of the CPU here we'll
just pull another one up that's great so
you end up having multiple of these uh I
know that you know sometimes people will
represent this by drawing multiple boxes
I typically don't horizontal scaling at
this point is it's pretty obvious um but
worth just calling out verbally in your
interview of course another thing that's
that's rather obvious is that we can
have you know we'll need a load balancer
load balancer API Gateway that can all
go here um so I'm going to say I'm going
to use an AWS managed API
Gateway
Gateway so that's going to be
responsible for handling routing
potentially some middleware it's going
to do some at least some load balancing
um but each of these horizontally scaled
Services have their own load balancers
that sit in front of them um but pretty
simple we've done that so far more
interestingly is the stream we need to
be able to allow this stream to scale so
in Kinesis for example we have a limit
of 1 Megabyte per second um or 1,000
records per second so let me write that
so this has a limit of
1,00
1,000 records per second um or 1
Megabyte per second whichever comes
first so we'll need some sharding here
uh we can Shard by at ID that's the
Natural Choice so Shard by at ID
um now with Flink it can also scale
horizontally um so this will have more
tasks or jobs they're referred to in
Flink and we can have a separate Flink
job reading from each Shard doing the
aggregation by add ID so we're going to
Shard by add ID here we're going to have
multiple of these they're going to be
reading from each Shard respectively
doing their aggregations great that's
all fine given that we shed by ad ID
there's kind of no distributed
contention issues because each Flink
instant is responsible for its own set
of AD IDs and no other Flink job has
that set of AD IDs that it's responsible
for S part's pretty simple and then same
too with our olap database if we need to
scale this by sharding we can do that as
well um this would probably be an
appropriate time to do a little bit of
math and determine kind of how large
this thing's going to get with its
aggregations um I'm going to spare you
guys that inline math here to but know
that that would be an appropriate thing
to do you'd probably want to
actually um shred this one by Advertiser
ID as opposed to ad
ID because that's probably the most
common query is that advertisers are
going to want to see like the
performance of all of their ads gosh
that spelling is horrible
Advertiser um so that's probably what
you would do there this is all
straightforward obvious stuff that you
do in most interviews now where this
gets interesting is what happens if you
have a new ad Nike just launched a new
ad it's got LeBron James everybody's
clicking on it and now you have a hot
Shard and particularly you'd have a hot
Shard here in Kinesis and this could be
a problem this could you know be
overwhelming it would
likely result in increased latency but
in worst case it could even cause some
data loss so to solve this hot Shard
problem we need a way of further
partitioning the data basically one
partition has far too many rights to it
we need to somehow further partition
that and kind of the most popular
approach for doing this uh is what's
called kind of the celebrity problem so
you end up doing is that you end up
adding to The Shard key to the primary
key some number between Zer and N so for
hot shards we would do something like
this you would Shard on ad ID and then
some number between zero and N depending
on how popular it is so maybe this is z
and 10 and this basically takes that
popular ad ID and then further shards it
n times right on to n different
partitions on to n different shards so
this is a really popular way to handle
that and so this is easy enough we can
do this this kind of has to get handled
in the click processor service The Click
processor service needs to know what's
popular it needs to make sure that it
does this additional uh kind of Z
through n on the primary key um or the
partition key before it writes the
Kinesis that's fine but then now I
talked about earlier how with Flink we
wouldn't have any given Flink job or two
Flink jobs responsible for the same set
of AD IDs where that could happen now so
that's a problem but ultimately since
Flink is in memory here it can actually
scale much better so what we would do is
we would just have a sing single Flink
job or a single flat uh Flink task still
for each ad ID even for the hot ones and
it would be responsible for aggregating
over a set of shards which is possible
Flink can aggregate over a set of
Kinesis shards so that's what we would
end up doing that way each Flink job or
task is still responsible for its own
set of AD IDs even if it's a hot Shard
even if it's hot ad ID um we would have
no issues there so that's how we would
handle scaling next up let's go back to
our non-functional requirements and this
time let's talk about fault tolerance
and data Integrity so specifically this
is how can we ensure that we don't lose
any click data so if we come back down
here let's start with our Stream So by
default these streams are distributed
they're fault tolerant they're highly
available you don't really need to worry
about them going down this is actually
true with both Kafka and kenesa streams
particularly if they're hosted and
managed it's something that we can kind
of look past you can assume that they're
always up that they're always available
so with that assumption in mind no
worries there but what happens if any of
these Flink jobs or tasks go down well
that could be an issue so what we want
to ensure is that we enable what's
called retention policies on this stream
so both CFA and Kinesis allow you to
enable retention periods and so we can
choose something like 7 days this is
configurable and what it means is that
even after events get read from the
consumer Flink in our case we keep them
in the Stream for that configurable
amount of time 7 Days in our case and
this is useful because then if Flint
goes down and it comes back online well
it can just read from where it left off
like that data is not gone it can pick
back up and start reading there again
even if it had read it before no worries
it has some cursor that understands
where it was prior to its last flush or
its last commit and it can pick back up
and start reading so that's great we're
going to enable that retention policy
let me actually note that so enable
7-Day retention policy
great um now stream processors like
Flink they also have a feature that's
called checkpointing and so this is
where they'll periodically write their
state to persistent storage something
like S3 so you could imagine
particularly if we were doing an
aggregation over a really large window
here like let's say even over a day then
we'd be keeping this data in memory for
a day if we went down say in the 23rd
hour then we would have 23 hours worth
of data to reread off that stream in
order to keep up and or catch up excuse
me and of course while doing that new
data is coming in so we could get caught
pretty far behind and this is why often
times we'll use checkpointing by
defaulting I think the checkpoint is 15
minutes you run the checkpoint every 15
minutes it might be 10 but it's around
there so a lot of candidates will when I
ask this question say I'm going to
enable uh checkpointing on Flink and
this is kind of like a common senior
engineer thing to say they've read it in
a book somewhere they know that
checkpointing is good for handling fault
tolerance um but unfortunately like
astute candidates and some some great
staff candidates in particular recognize
that this doesn't make any sense like
why would we use checkpointing when our
aggregation windows are so small our
aggregation window is only a minute so
at most we have a minute worth of data
that we need to go read off of the
stream at 10,000 clicks per second this
is 10,000 * 60 it's not that many events
and checkpointing doesn't even really
help us we're going to check point
halfway through that at the 302 Mark uh
and this would just mean that we have
all of this data that we're writing to
S3 uh that's unnecessary you know S3 is
pretty cheap but it's still more
expensive than it needs to be and given
the small aggregation Windows it doesn't
make much sense so I would argue that
you wouldn't use checkpointing here uh
as a rule of thumb if the aggregation
window is less than 5 minutes depending
on how kind of the rate of events in
your stream probably doesn't make sense
to checkpoint and so as a a staff
candidate as a great senior candidate
maybe you would point that out you would
say I know a lot of candidates might
bring up checkpoints in here it's
something to consider but because of the
small aggregation Windows I'm going to
opt to actually not use checkpointing
that shows some Nuance there some
sophistication that really sets apart
those senior
candidates now one thing though is that
click data M matters a ton of course if
we lose clicks we can lose money so
despite our best efforts with these
retention policies um with how we're
going to handle Flink if it goes down
there can still be errors like there can
be transient processing errors in Flink
there can be bad code pushes from
employees out of order events in the
Stream this can all lead to really
slight inaccuracies in our data and so
it shouldn't happen a lot in fact it
should be relatively uncommon but any
inaccuracies are an issue to us so
because we need really high data
Integrity as defined in our
non-functional requirements we're
actually going to want to introduce
something called periodic reconciliation
and this means that we're essentially
going to have a job that runs maybe once
a day maybe once every hour kind of
either of those work in this case but
they're going to take that batch
processing solution from earlier and
apply it here as well and so the way
this is going to work is that uh we can
enable Kinesis to dump raw click events
to S3 and I think there's actually other
connectors such that it doesn't have to
be S3 S3 is the one that I'm I'm
familiar with here and I I don't want to
say anything that's
inaccurate um in this recording but feel
free to look it up on your own time
basically kis allows you it has some
integration with these things that they
call connectors and it means that it'll
dump those events as well as whatever
consumer is hooked up it'll dump those
to you know um to that data store S3
being the one that that I know it
certainly supports so you would dump it
to S3 and then you would do all of those
things that we talked about before so
I'm going to add here
my spark map
reduce we'll have that Cron job which is
just going to be necessary for kicking
it off of course every in this case now
hour or day so we'll say day not too
important that we do it more frequently
than than that um it would it would
depend on the business needs and when we
need to have perfect accuracy um but
then you're going to have
some Boop maybe we'll call this our Reon
ilation
worker and so spark is as it did before
going to read those raw click events
it's going to do its aggregations and
then it's going to give that data to
this reconciliation worker which is
going to be a server that's responsible
for potentially
fixing uh incorrect
records so it's going to compare the
data that it has
potentially it's going to compare the
data that it got from this spark job
from this map Produce job to the data in
our database base which came from the
flank aggregations and if anything's
different we're going to trust the
reconciliation worker is correct so
we're going to overwrite or we're going
to fix that data we'd also probably want
to event or alert the team at this point
too to let them know that there were
some inconsistencies we'd probably have
some um some logging some observations
over this as well if this ever started
to increase then we know something's
broken here that we need to fix but what
we've ultimately done is we've combined
that first solution that we had up here
which wasn't great um such so now we get
the both The Best of Both Worlds we get
that real-time processing and then we
also have the reconciliation in order to
make sure that our data Integrity is
incredibly
high now this this video this interview
maybe would would be incomplete if I
didn't at least mention Lambda and Kappa
architectures so I don't want to go into
too much detail here but some viewers
May realize that this is neither a Kappa
nor a Lambda architecture and I'll come
back to that in just one moment but for
the uninitiated let me kind of describe
what both of these are so first Lambda
and cap Kappa architectures they're data
processing architectures for handling
large scale data processing systems like
this one so in a Kappa architecture we
design for stream processing we treat
all data as a continuous stream and we
rely solely on that real time processing
layer so actually what we had here
before we added the reconciliation this
was a traditional Kappa architecture you
got a stream you have some stream
processor you handle everything sort of
in quote unquote real Time That's a cap
architecture now a Lambda architecture
is similar to what we had here and that
it uses batching but to satisfy that
issue of you know we had 5 minutes that
we had to wait it has some real time
layer that's not guaranteed to be
accurate but it's sort of you could
imagine some other service or other
worker here that's handling the
aggregation on 5 minute windows and kind
of writing those to the database and
then they ultimately get
overwritten um
by the by the batch processing job and
so we make no guarantees that things are
accurate within five minutes but we want
to give you real- time data and then
after five minutes it becomes accurate
that's more or less what a Lambda
architecture is and so you'll notice
here we're not Lambda or Kappa we we
kind of combined the two and so I I've
had candidates kind of bring up to me
they go oh what's going on here like is
this okay can we have both like does
this break something and the answer is
of course it's okay and actually using a
hybrid approach like combining aspects
of Lambda and Kappa architectures it's
not frowned upon in fact it it's
incredibly practical in many scenarios
like this one um and I think it's really
important to remember that like these
architectural patterns that you can read
in textbooks they serve as guidelines
they're not strict rules so being able
to adapt them to fit specific business
needs or operational context contexts
excuse me this is super common um and
honestly it it shows seniority so it
shows that you haven't just read
textbooks and you have this academic
understanding but you understand the
practicality of software engineering um
so maybe to summarize this is applicable
outside of the context of this question
it's even applicable outside of these
two architectures Lambda uh and Kappa
and it's that practicality should almost
always be favored over some abstract
Purity in an academic sense so I think
this is pretty good evidence of that and
candidates who are able ble to handle
that Nuance again are indicative of
seniority so this is something that tops
or that staff candidates and top senior
candidates will recognize of course
there are potential solutions to this
particularly with the Lambda
architecture which are passing as well
pure Lambda architecture I would push
back on the accuracy of those first five
minutes or n minutes until you handle
the the batch processing as I think this
solution is a bit more sophisticated um
but that is what that is um maybe I'm
actually not going to write it here but
this next cut so that you guys have this
um in the linked whiteboard I'll maybe
put a summary over here to the left of
Kappa and Lambda architectures just so
you all have it as a written Resource as
well all right just like that I I think
that just about does it so to recap we
satisfied our functional requirements in
our highle design then we went through
each of our non-functional requirements
and kind of expanded our highle design
through deep Di to be something that was
more sufficient now what we have here is
something that is passable for a staff
candidate for a senior candidate I think
you could have left out the
reconciliation that's fine you might not
have had time to get to the item potency
I would have liked some depth whether it
was in understanding how to scale
Kinesis or retention policies we
definitely would have required some
knowledge there and I think I'd like to
see you at least get to uh you know this
Kappa architecture though there are
strong justifications for the Lambda
that maybe could have passed for senior
as well um for mid- level as we
discussed before even if you got here
then I would have asked some follow-up
questions in different areas kind of
probed a couple of places to fill out
our 35 minutes but assuming you answered
all of those pretty eloquently and had a
good understanding this probably would
have been passable at midlevel so
hopefully this gives you a good
understanding of what would be required
at each level the main tradeoff there
just to summarize is that as you are
more Junior then we have more depth or
more breadth excuse me and less depth so
for a mid-level candidate we look for
80% breadth 20% depth at a senior
candidate we now want more depth so
maybe we're looking at more 60 70 bread
30 40 depth and then of course at a
staff candidate we want you to Breeze
through the breadth we know that you
understand the basics get that high
level design really down really quickly
and let's spend a lot of time going deep
talking about the things that are comp
complex and interesting and more
importantly with staff candidates often
times you'll find some place in this
architecture that you have intimate
familiarity with from your past work and
you can even teach the interviewer
something about it I think usually it's
a Telltale sign that a staff candidate
did well when I leave the interview
Having learned something myself so that
wraps it up I'm pretty happy with this
design hopefully you are uh all are as
well great job if you made it this far I
know these are long I've been trying to
keep them short but there's a lot of
things that I want to talk about uh
hopefully it was it was informative I'm
going to continue to publish these once
every 3 weeks that's been the Cadence
thus far I've been holding myself to
that uh please continue to leave
comments ask questions tell me other the
things that I've done wrong I enjoy
responding to those comments I try my
best to keep up to date as they're
coming in and and and provide those
responses also kind of the the Kudos the
praise whatnot in the comments has been
super encouraging too that's really
what's been motivating me to continue
doing these a lot of people are finding
them incredibly useful so
um thank you so much for those kind
words uh truthfully it motivates me to
keep going now lastly if you want to
practice with me or somebody like me a
former or current Fang uh senior plus
engineer or manager then head over to
hello interview.com and schedule a mock
interview um obviously I'm biased I run
a mock interview site but I'm I'm fully
bought in to this idea of mock
interviews being incredibly effective
even outside of my bias I get messages
from candidates every single day
multiple messages a day of folks that
either I worked with directly or we've
worked with through hello interview um
and they express you know immense
gratitude they got the job and they're
so thankful for for having worked with
us and they really credit a large
portion of that success to the mock
interviews so I'm bought into this being
something that that really works and
helps candidates prefare prepare um and
you know worth considering if it makes
sense for you so with that being said
uh thanks for watching I'll see you all
again in 3 weeks and best of luck with
your upcoming interviews you're going to
do great